There's been a lot of buzz
about dubious chemicals in the environment
that might contribute to
some pretty frightening stuff
like obesity, breast
cancer, thyroid issues.
And they seem to lurk everywhere:
in pesticides, cosmetics, and
especially plastic packaging.
In light of this,
it's understandable to start panicking.
But before you do,
let's hear what molecular
biologist Bruce Blumberg
has to say on the subject.
He's been studying the link
between synthetic chemicals
and obesity for around 15 years.
So he might be able to
give us a better idea
of what's really going on
and what to do about it.
Bad news is, Blumberg confirmed that, yep,
we're surrounded by these chemicals.
One of the most well known is BPA,
or Bisphenol A,
which shows up in water
bottles, cans, milk cartons,
and more.
Bruce: You get them from
thermal paper receipts.
Like I have,
I have these receipts from a recent trip.
All of these things are
coated with Bisphenol A.
It goes right into your skin.
Narrator: BPA has been
making headlines for years
about whether or not it's harming us.
And while FDA-funded
and independent studies
have conflicting conclusions,
the bigger heart of the issue is this:
BPA is hard to get away from
because it's a key building
block in the tough,
clear, flexible plastic
called polycarbonate.
And that proximity to food
is what concerns scientists
like Blumberg.
You don't want to store food in plastics
because some fraction of those plastics
will leach into your food.
Narrator: The BPA molecules
that make up plastic
are bound together by
what's called an ester bond,
which is extremely sensitive to heat.
So when you heat up your food in plastic,
that heat breaks some of the bonds,
releasing the chemicals into your food.
A survey by the CDC of 2,517 people
estimated that over 90% of Americans
have detectable levels
of BPA in their urine.
And BPA isn't alone.
Phthalates, which make plastic flexible,
can also leach into food when heated.
And reviews of hundreds
of studies have linked BPA
and phthalates to heart disease, obesity,
and Type 2 diabetes.
Not to mention a 2015
review linked phthalates
with impaired neurological
development in children,
which in 2018 prompted the
American Academy of Pediatrics
to announce that families should
avoid plastic food containers entirely.
And other studies on animals,
like mice and monkeys,
have shown that these
chemicals can lead to problems
in the lungs, brains,
and reproductive organs.
This is about the time someone like me
would probably panic.
But there are ways you
can avoid these chemicals.
Blumberg suggests it's best to just stick
to heating your food in
anything but plastic.
Now, quick aside, BPA-free
plastic containers aren't
the answer
because research suggests
that BPS and BPF,
the most common replacements for BPA,
might have similar effects on your body.
Instead, opt for replacements like ceramic
or glass containers.
Bruce: You have to do the best you can,
and it makes sense to me to do the things
that give you the most
return for the least effort.
Narrator: And here's the best part.
Once you reduce exposure,
those chemicals slowly leave your body.
As Blumberg says, they're
stored in fat cells,
which eventually die and
ultimately leave your system.
Bruce: Don't stress about it, right?
Do your best
and make conscious
choices to improve things.